you open the doorway between universes
we don't know who or what will walk
through it
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness truly could have felt like a
different universe without the cast
we've come to know so we're looking at
how they landed their roles in the mcu
and whose rejection almost changed the
timeline it is something very different
from what they've seen number one
madness in great ones must not unwatched
go benedict cumberbatch was the first
choice for the role of doctor strange
scott derrickson flew to london with
some concept art to meet with him it was
clear after that meeting it had to be
him but they ran into a conflict he was
doing hamlet at the national theater at
the time so they started looking
elsewhere cumberbatch was honest with
derekson saying i can't bail out of
hamlet i've given my word but it was
pretty apparent it needed to be benedict
so they were willing to push the entire
shooting and release schedule to wait
for him but scheduling conflicts wasn't
benedict's only problem from what he'd
seen in the comics he felt doctor
strange was dated and sexist so he
really considered passing on the part
marvel told cumberbatch to not worry
since he would be playing an updated
version of the character benedict
finally said yes and just 36 hours after
hamlet ended he was doctor strange
shooting in nepal
so we got the right place
that one looks a little more number two
the stress was unreal
elizabeth olsen didn't audition for
scarlet witch she was offered the part
over tea with joss whedon tea drinking
is always intense he told her look up
this character and don't think about the
costumes when you look her up because
you're not gonna look like that sure he
said then she wouldn't look like the
comic hero but he broke his promise in
wandavision
infringing on doctor strange's solo
story came as a surprise to her she knew
nothing about her role until she got the
verbal pitch she was two months to the
end of wandavision right after they
returned from the covet shutdowns just
days after her show ended olson entered
the multiverse of madness filming it
certainly felt like um i was in a
multiverse of madness it was kind of
chaotic at times number three america's
next star
in march 2020 sochi had her first self
tape audition and it was for an unknown
marvel project she didn't hear anything
for six months then she got a call in
august to tape again but with a
completely new fake script and character
name she put together what the project
was when the word sorcerer appeared but
still had no idea her character was
america chavez a little over a week
later she got an offer to screen test in
london this was the scary audition there
were four cameras roughly 80 crew
members and every important person there
and she did her scene with benedict
cumberbatch himself sochi said as
intimidating as it was everyone made me
feel welcome elizabeth olsen she gave me
fantastic advice number four fans were
way ahead of feige with their mordo
dream casting chuatel edgio4 has always
been a big fan of marvel films and was
excited by the way they've been pushing
the envelope guardians of the galaxy is
what really impressed him so he met with
kevin feige and said listen i'm excited
to get involved so let me know what's
going on they got talking about doctor
strange and he said getting into that
universe and getting into that kind of
concept was so thrilling but it was a
great cast you know i couldn't choose i
couldn't imagine a better cast for this
for this film number five benedict with
benedict wong for wong chuatel and wong
were working on the martian together and
while having lunch he told wong he was
going to be doing this thing called
doctor strange wong looked it up on the
internet and saw a photo of strange with
comic wong peeping out on the side and
his jaw dropped that's when his petition
joke wong for wong began i get this
mysterious email with hi we'd like you
to audition for the part he saw he got
the part when he was on the set of marco
polo as kublai khan while sitting on a
throne sworn to mcu secrecy he texted
chuatel and said wong is wong we wonder
if chiwetel had any influence over that
it's weird having two benedicts on a
movie uh that's rare just one
like adele number six who stole my
likeness and put it in a comic when
patrick stewart was first considered for
professor x he had no idea who the
character was so when one of the
producers handed him an x-men comic from
the desk he responded what am i doing on
the front of a comic book we call that
perfect casting let's have a little tiny
audition then what about uh you say
make it so
number seven do as peggy says and give
her the role haley atwell had to perform
peggy carter and steve's tragic radio
call at the film's climax where steve
sacrificed himself they were all sitting
there in a quiet room chris evans wasn't
in town so one of the assistants was off
camera reading for him and everyone
wanted to burst into tears it's safe to
say she nailed it number eight i am on
my way i can go the distance jet klein's
story of landing tommy maximoff is one
of dedication his family drove 10 hours
every audition they did 435
000 miles of driving just for auditions
by the age of eight jett was signed to
an agent in the us number nine now
paging dr palmer
rachel mcadams was in talks for doctor
strange but she just didn't think the
conversation was going to go anywhere
this is one of those roles she probably
should have turned down and waited on a
more prominent part to come along either
way she's here now we love her and the
multiverse ripping apart has created
possibilities for her character playing
different versions of ourselves so
you kind of get to start fresh
number 10 finally the mr fantastic the
world's been waiting for the story of
john krasinski's casting starts way back
at his captain america audition despite
not landing the role he's been on
feige's mind ever since
in my head i got the part right before
his audition krasinski recalls having
the captain america suit half on when
the super jacked chris hemsworth walked
by and he was like you look good mate
you're gonna look great in that suit and
krazynski was just thinking don't make
fun of me hemsworth i love you thor
number 11. the most problematic casting
in the mcu there are a ton of regrets
from feige and tilda swinton over her
casting as the ancient one in doctor
strange feige admitted we thought we
were being so smart and so cutting edge
we're not going to do the cliche of the
wisened old wise asian man but that was
a moment they regret not thinking is
there any other way to both not fall
into the cliche and cast an asian actor
at least the one place they did make a
good call was with wong's character not
being a servant to strange like in the
comics but instead a mentor
unfortunately though their lesson had to
be learned the hard way the ancient one
was irresistible to me number 12 it's
not you it's the character
there's a long list of runner-ups for
doctor strange who have managed to snag
roles as other characters whether that
be for marvel or dc joaquin phoenix was
the second choice for strange he was
considering it but ultimately found it
would take up too much creative energy
then he went and played the joker the
other joker jared leto was considered
and later landed morbius with sony ethan
hawks now got the awesome roll of harrow
in moon night jake gyllenhaal landed
right where he belonged playing mysterio
tom hardy eventually starred in sony's
venom instead and let's not forget ryan
gosling who has yet to join the mcu or
dc we wonder if he was a contender due
to his history with rachel mcadams in
the notebook we can't fathom the idea of
someone else playing doctor strange
benedict cumberbatch is just so perfect
we can see why they were willing to wait
for him how romantic while we aren't
sure if we believe in multiverses we do
believe in ripple effects how do you
think the mcu would be different if
someone else were to play doctor strange
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things